سؤال اخر حول نفس الموضوع حلتي كيف كانت
ردود افعل الرئيس بشان التهم الموجهه
لترامب تعنينا يوم الامس الرئيس
هو كما
ذكرت كان قد تحدث الى الشعب الامريكي وهذا
سوف يكون محطه اهتمامه وعلى حال ما جرى في
الاسبوع الماضي
كنا قد سمعنا برائحه الاتهام وقد تم
اطلاعهم من قبل فريقه وموظفيه حول هذا
الامر وكلنا علمنا من خلال التقارير
الاعلاميه هذا كل ما لدينا بالنسبه
للاجتماع حول
الرئيس رئيس التايوان
واجتماعها مع السيد مكار به هل هناك اي
حديث عن تمارين عسكريه قد تجري بين
الولايات المتحده دعوني اكرر ما قاله
الوزير بلينكل لعلكم سمعتموه في اكثر من
المناسبه
ما ذكره في اجتماع وزراء النيتو في بروكسل
كنا واضحين في هذا الشان فقد قلنا بانه ما
من سبب يدفع لبيجين
لتحويل هذا المضيق
لاستخدامه كدريعه لابداء اي ردود افعال
ممكنه كنا واضحين
بان هذا بان هذا المضيق هو مهم
وعلاقتنا مع
تايلاند علاقتنا مع تايوان هي علاقه عريقه
وقديمه وما من سبب يدفع الصين لتبدا اي
ردود افعالهم غريبه سؤال اخر
لقد
قد يقوم الرئيس باجراء رحله في الفتره
القادمه
مع من سوف يستعمل لا اعلم اذا ما كانت سوف
من سوف يكون بصحبه الرئيس في رحلته من سوف
يكون من افراد اسرته
دعوني اعطيكم
بعض المعلومات التي قد تتضح خلال الايام
القليله القادمه
لقد تم اجراء حديثا مع الرئيس سوف يتوجه
لزياره الى المملكه المتحده وايرلندا
هاتان البلدان اللتان تجمعنا علاقه قويه
في ذلك زياره بالفاس وكانت ميو
لكن كما اسلفت الحديث انه يتطلع الى هذه
الزياره وسوف
سوف سوف
يسلط الضوء على ان اسرته تشاطر تاريخا
كبيرا مع ايرلندا ونحن المهاجرون
الايرلنديون كنا قد شاطرنا هذه العلاقات
التي
ترتكز على الصداقه التي تجمع بلدينا وفي
هذا السياق سوف تكون هذه الرحله مهمه
لاسرته بالاضافه لذلك هناك الجاليه
الايرلنديه الامريكيه التي سوف تنظر الى
كيفيه تشكيل هذه البلاد لذا فان الرئيس
يتطلع الى هذه الرحله
ما استطيع ان اقوله هذا مع عكفنا على
تكراره منذ اشهر اننا نعتقد
انه
قد قد قام الكونجرس
بالتعاطي مع هذه المساله من قبل الحزبين
بطريقه منفصله
وكان هناك توجه لرفع عقوبه الاعدام
من الدستور
وانه ما من مفاوضات بان قد نجريها بشان
هذا الموضوع لانها مساله
قد يجدر بالكونجرس ان يتداول بشكل